the choking smoke makes the day look
like night
wildfires have been searing away parts
of argentina's northeastern province of
corientes brought on by drought and high
temperatures
this is a typical historic it's never
happened we've never lived something
like this we're really overwhelmed this
is what i can tell you now this is a
blue for the province
this region is dependent on agriculture
around 10 percent of its land has been
destroyed by the fires that have burned
for days
local people have joined the
firefighters to help
the truth is that koryanta's provinces
went through a catastrophe with the
fires a lot of animals flora and fauna
have been lost and on top of that
there's the jobs what is to become of us
if it's all lost tomorrow
some rain started to fall on sunday
night desperately needed to help wet the
dry flammable land
it makes me feel powerless to help all
the people because we all live here and
to protect the animals and our land
which is the most important thing
the fire is also getting closer to a
national park in the area one of
argentina's largest ecosystems
many animals have been killed
repairing the damage is expected to cost
millions of dollars the governor of the
province has declared it an ecological
and environmental disaster zone
stephanie decker al jazeera